[Music]
what I'm doing shows I listen to a lot
of music beetle music wings music to see
what ones were going to do and to learn
them yeah what do you mean you forgotten
oh yeah really it's too many too many
words too many notes they're very hard I
mean you know it's not like they're all
three chords sorry when you write so
many great songs we all assume those
songs are unforgettable but partment
paul mccartney told Sharon alphonse he
of 60 minutes they are not the Beatles
had 20 number-one singles on the
Billboard Hot 100 pop chart and they
remain one of the most influential bands
of all time a new movie yesterday is set
in a different world where an aspiring
singer named Jack is the only musician
who remembers the Beatles becomes famous
pretending all those great songs
yesterday all my troubles seemed so far
away now it seems as though they're here
to say I didn't write it Paul McCartney
wrote it the Beatles John Paul George
and Ringo the Beatles Patel who plays
Jack is with us along with director
Danny Boyle good morning to you both
welcome this is such a great premise but
I imagined I mean casting the lead must
be very difficult you know you get you
get a singer who can act inaccurate who
can sing and you basically said to
message saved you in this case yes you
have to knit you narrow the field down
very quickly because it's not like horse
riding actors will promise you that they
can ride a horse but he turned up and it
was extraordinary you knew he was the
guy straightaway yeah so it's all sang
with soul I mean you can't kind of
manufacture it you can ruin it if you're
not careful but you can't manufacture it
and he had that special quality and
that's you actually singing himesh we
just heard Paul McCartney say how hard
it is to know the words you had to learn
so many number one were you a Beatles
fan at first I was not as big a fan as I
am now
you are going on this journey has made
me a huge fan of them but I kind of knew
what we all tend to know and I had a
copy the album you sang those songs live
in the film and yes we didn't overdub
anything so everything you hear in the
movie is me singing live and playing
guitar live yeah and not only is singing
Beatles songs but you're doing some of
them in front of Ed Sheeran yeah what
was that like yeah it was strange at the
first actually the first time we met
Ed's Danny made me sing long and winding
road in front of ed with no instruments
so I just had to sing a cappella this
year five minutes after meeting though
performance of that in the movie by the
way it's a terrific thing it's really
terrific and Ed Sheeran is one of the
surprises of this film because he's
quite a good actor yes he is he came to
rehearsal
we've hit your first choice for the role
as a better cast the enemy I think great
see you as Chris and yes so we asked her
honey he wasn't available so then of
course we we went to ad and lied and
said ed you're our first choice and he
said no I'm not you just asked Christmas
and all the pop stars have a Facebook
prior no what was it like negotiating
with the The Beatles catalog and you
talked to Paul and Ringo and and their
widows this is a story about them being
forgotten how do you get approval for
that I think that's their sense of humor
because it's not like a straight buy
opaque or a life story like so many
films these days they had such a sense
of humor as a group I think they like
the idea of let's do one where we are
erased from the world's consciousness
and see what happens yeah so that appeal
to the mother it is not easy to get
approval of the Beatles because every
each of the four members of the family
have to sign off don't they yeah it's
one for all all for one yeah yeah where
they do it I like what you said how much
that the the movie makes a point of not
addressing the character's ethnicity
right which I also thought was a very
interesting way to do it yeah is that
been difficult for you to find roles
like that
um actually been quite lucky yeah in the
last few years of kind of being out here
auditioning I think there's been a
change in the narrative because people
are speaking up on
new platforms and and being listened to
in different ways yeah you did that on
purpose Danny
it's just quality I mean it's just
talent outs you know I wouldn't have
cast him if I'd phone somebody better
he's a terrible thing to say but you
know it's true he was the best and it's
so it's a triumph or Talent really over
over kind of other systems of you know
stardom or what some people might think
are appropriate you know one of my
favorite lines in the movie is a world
without Beatles as a world that's
infinitely worse which i think is so
true it made me want to go and play all
the Beatles songs that I had
unimaginable today I agree with you
Anthony were you've just a huge Beatles
fan how did this premise come about I
it's one of our leading writers which he
curses
he's a Beatles is a crazy Beatles fan
don't let him trap you in an elevator I
actually probably would like to take
that and he borrowed the idea it's
interesting because so much of this is
about borrowing other people's he
borrowed the idea of this writer Jack
bath and what this wonderful script and
I think it does have the joy of their
work in it you know it's a joyful
there's some solemn moments in it some
very tender yeah melancholy moments in
it but it has joy in it like their songs
yes it does a lot of joy I really
enjoyed it thank you both thank you
brother Bravo Danny Boyle and knish
Patel yesterday's in theaters this
Friday you're watching CBS this morning
you thank you we'll be right back
you